you are as well
here's beal with a screen from gayle
out to kuzma for three oh and he hits
and the bulls use their last timeout
kuzma missed on the last trip down four
but he makes up for it on this one
[Applause]
boy kyle kuzma is shooting 32 from three
on the year it's made a couple tonight
there's the health defense
eric jones jr trying to stop the ball
bradley beal
flipping it to kuzma and kyle kuzma
making the biggest shot of the night
now has been dialed in for all 48.
[Music]
[Applause]
got it again
and the buzzer
damar delivers
again
and dc
we will let ourselves out
bulls win again at the buzzer
words cannot do it justice
and the wizards are speechless
they will review
i mean this is like groundhog's day this
is so well defended demar derozan taking
his time doesn't panic bradley beal
coming right back into the play
but mr fourth quarter himself demar
derozan delivering once again in the
chicago bulls stealing on the road here
in washington d.c how about the patience
with that pumping he knew exactly how
much time he had and that is so big time
by demar derozan
the review
is good
oh and the bulls
are better than good
rack up a seventh straight win for
chicago
that winning streak was on the brink of
expiration after the cal kuzma 3 with
3.3 seconds left but 3.3 all demar
derozan needed
for another cold-blooded
heroics